sens public continue pour notre second
débat c'est un mot que je vous propose
d'analyser
réindustrialisation c'est un objectif
affiché du président de la République
une évidence après la crise sanitaire
qui a affiché notre perte de
souveraineté pour produire les batteries
tiens de nos voitures ou nos futur
voiture électrique par exemple faut du
lithium et donc rouvrir des mines en
France comme avec ce projet dans
l'Allier on état et chassière avec audre
vetas on va être à 50 m en ENF en
dessous de du plus bas pour l'heure ce
n'est qu'une simple car de caolin la
matière première de la porcelaine de
Limoge mais d'ici 2027 il y aura ici au
cœur de l'alliier l'une des plus grandes
mines européenne de lithium on aura une
galerie qui va rentrer sous sous terre
et on va aller à une cinquantaine de
mètres en dessous de la carrière
actuelle pour aller sortir le granite
blanc qui contient le le lithium le
lithium lui est piégé dans des minéraux
au sein de ce granite donc c'est
difficile de le voir à l'œil nu c'est
des analyses chimiques qui qui nous
disent exactement quels sont les les
teneurs et la production pourrait être
exceptionnel pendant au moins 25 ans on
parle de 34000 tonnes par an c'est
l'équivalent de 700000 batteries pour
voiture électrique par an donc c'est ça
représente à peu près 2000 2000
batteries par jour donc c'est c'est
quand même des quantités assez
impressionnantes tellement que le projet
est soutenu par le gouvernement il
devrait permettre à la France et à
l'Union européenne de se défaire de leur
dépendan chinois en matière de lithium
pour équiper les voitures électriques
les seuls véhicules qu'il sera possible
d'acheter neuf à partir de 2035 c'est
une ressource qui est hyper stratégique
dans la transition énergétique pour la
souveraineté de la France la
souveraineté européenne et maîtriser une
filière aussi de A à Z iméris le porteur
de projet promet de créer entre 5 et 600
emplois dans la région sur deux sites
différents à échassière la commune de
400 habitants où se situera la mine la
nouvelle est accueillie chez certains
avec espoir moi je me dis que ça fait
des des nouvelles familles qui arrivent
dans la région donc ils vont faire
travailler le commerce local donc c'est
bien pour le village et les alentours je
pense que ça va emmener des emplois et
voilà mais mais en même temps on
aimerait enfin moi personnellement
j'aimerais plus
d'information des inquiétudes carré
chassière a un passé minier qui a déjà
laissé des traces alors là on voit un
vieux bidon qui a été jeté dans la mine
qui date de l'époque de la mine de 1962
quand ils ont arrêté la mine ils ont
tout jeté dans les dans les les trous
ici on sait aujourd'hui que les sols
sont très chargés en plomb enrees en
arsenic dans l'eau donc c'est des lieux
qui sont très très beau qui sont en plus
classé Natura 2000 mais malheureusement
qui n'ont plus de bah qui sont sont
pourriso iméris promet d'adopter des
standards pour réduire les rejets de la
mine mais il y a aussi la question de
l'eau qui pose problème dans une forêt
de être déjà touchée par le
réchauffement climatique ces dernières
années avec toutes les sécheresses
successives qu'on a eu les niveaux d'eau
ont baissé et donc il y a moins moins
d'eau en réalité si on fait un trou en
plus de l'autre côté ça va tout
s'infiltrer il y aura vraiment plus
d'eau ici pour d'autres c'est tout le
projet qui pose question on est contre
le modèle de société qui rend ce besoin
de lithium disponible et rouler tous en
SUV électrique demain c'est pas viable
c'est pas possible des interrogations
qui feront l'objet d'un débat public
l'an prochain c'est obligatoire pour
tous les projets qui ont un impact
majeur sur l'environnement l'aménagement
ou l'économie d'un territoire la
peut-elle redevenir un pays industriel
cette ambition est-elle compatible avec
les enjeux les nouvelles règles de
protection de l'environnement on en
débat avec Christine cardellan bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
économique et esséiste Olivier bonsoir
et bienvenue signateur Union centriste
du Nord Jérôme ci bonsoir et bienvenue à
vous aussi vous êtes chercheur
enseignant en socio-économie écologique
auteur de ce livre relocalisé publié aux
éditions Tana et évidemment Émilie
zapalski spécialiste en communication
politique éditorialiste pour sens public
est resté à mes côtés on commence sur
les mines puis ensuite on élargira un
petit peu à la question centrale de ce
débat sur la
réindustrialisation est-ce que la France
peut redevenir un pays minier d'après
vous Christine cardelland quand on voit
les les freins les les les difficultés
l'acceptabilité ça va être compliqué
alors évidemment on a moins de réserve
que la Chine c'est une raison mais on
avait effectivement des mines qu'on a
abandonné pendant les années 70 80 et
euh ça va être très difficile de le
faire revenir parce que on l'a vu dans
le reportage les les populations sont
pas forcément d'accord et puis parce que
de fait c'est effectivement poant même
s'il y a des nouvelles techniques
d'extraction et ce mais pour les
médicaments c'est la même chose les
principes actifs des médicaments sont
partis peu à peu en Inde ou en Chine et
c'est ce qui a fait que pendant le le
covid on avait plus de paracétamol ou
d'autres types de de de principes actifs
ENF en tout cas de produits
médicamenteux donc ça va être compliqué
euh il faut le faire accepter mais une
des personnes du reportage disait c'est
un modèle de société si tout le monde
Roulin et suivit on y' arrivera pas et
on sera bien obligé oui je crois je
crois que tout le problème est là h et
bon la France est pas forcément la mieux
placée pour faire revenir des mines
enfin ou réexploiter des mines sur son
sol cela dit il y a aussi une solution
intermédiaire qui est de de pouvoir
faire venir ces matériaux critiques de
pays amis parce qu'aujourd'hui le
problème c'est que ils viennent ils
vienent essentiellement de Chine voilà
qui nous fourn aujourd'hui c'est la
Chine oui et donc on l'a vu pendant le
covid quand la Chine ne fournit plus h
et c'est pour ça que cette question de
réindustrialisation elle est forcément
liée avec la question de la souveraineté
économique c'est une évidence rouvrir
les mines évocateur évidemment pour un
département comme comme le vôre Olivier
dans dans le Nord est-ce que vous
espérez que l'inventaire du BRGM là le
le bureau de recherche géologique et
minière permettent de relancer des des
des projets miniers dans le Nord bah
pourquoi pas on y pense par rapport à à
l'hydrogène d'un certain point de vue
nous dans dans les Haut- de France on on
vit une époque incroyable
un nouvel essur industriel savez avec
Xavier Bertrand en 2015 on avait défini
cet objectif moi j'était pas sûr de voir
arriver ces
gigafory ces usines de batteries on a
connu dans les Haut- de France le déclin
industriel à l'époque Pierre monroi
disait il faut faire face à ça et il y a
les turbines les turbines tertièires je
reprends son son terme et et donc on a
connu cette are tertière avec la
division internationale du travail on a
vu les limites et aujourd'hui on a fixé
cet objectif j'aime pas le terme de
réindustrialisé parce que c'est pas la
même chose hein c'est pas la nouvelle
industrie c'est pas c'est pas l'ancienne
industrie qui revient c'est une toute
nouvelle industrie Industri parindustrie
verte NOTAM qui qui c'est la fin du
moteur à explosion hein monsieur Lenoir
belge là qui avait inventé ce moteur à
explosion il y a 150 ans c'est la fin de
ça qu'on vit et par rapport à ça si on n
arrive pas à avoir une nouvelle
industrie et à s'adapter et bien on
manquera quelque chose
et nous dans les haut de
franceer laembre 30000 emplois qui vont
se créer onaurait rêvé on
a faut mieux avoir du lithium made in
France ENF ext en franceou après c'est
une autre
question déjà 30000 emplois les
logements d'uner nous on a géré le
déclin et maintenant on gère un nouvel
essort c'est quand même mieux
voilà y a ce terme angloaxon NBI not in
my backyard pas de ça dans mon quartier
en quelque sorte on est en plein
là-dedans Jérôme ci l'acceptabilité et
je reste sur les mines pour l'instant on
parlera des projets industriels
mais on est face à une espèce de de de
conflit de de d'intérêt ou de loyauté je
sais pas quel TER employé d' ce côté on
dit oui de toute façon il faut retrouver
notre souveraineté de l'autre bah oui
mais à quel prix ce qu'on j'appelle
souvent des injonctions contradictoires
c'està-dire on veut réindustrialiser
mais il y aura nécessairement des
impacts et en fait j'ai envie de dire
ramener des mines oui c'est compliqué
vous avez parfaitement raison sauf que
ça ça nous permettrait d'arrêter
d'invisibiliser tout ça c'est-à-dire
quand on parle d'importer de pays amis
faut voir dans quelles conditions donc
par exemple les conditions dans cette
mine devrait être bien meilleur
qu'ailleurs il parle par exemple de
diviser par deux les émissions de
carbone de l'extraction du lithium c'est
loin d'être parfait mais ça serait pas
mal qu'on réalise d'où vient ces
matériaux et comprendre que les objets
qu'on a l'impression qui débarquent
magiquement dans nos mains soit dans les
boutiques soit par internet ont tout un
chemin qui démarre avec des mines les
avoir à côté condition de travail qui
sont évidment pas les mêmes que
sur exct et on n'arrête pas de parler de
sobriété réaliser d'où viennent les
matières première peut-être nous fera
réaliser que c'est pas magique ni pour
l'environnement ni pour l'humain et que
les volumes vont être une vraie question
et on est les ayant à côté de chez nous
on va peut-être plus réaliser ce que ça
signifie d'acheter des objets ouis mais
comment rendre ces projets acceptables
pour les riverins Christine can il faut
les il faut un intéressement on se pose
les mêmes questions par exemple pour les
éoliennes aussi hein est-ce qu'il faut
un intéressement financier mettons les
pieds dans le plat c'est une question
qu'on a jamais qu'on a jamais vraiment
posé comme ça pour l'instant la première
solution c'est de montrer que
l'extraction telle qu'on l'a fait chez
nous va être beaucoup moins polluante
que si on on fait venir des matières en
en d'Inde ou de Chine et dans ce cas-là
que au total pour la planète finalement
c'est meilleur puisquil y a pas de
déplacement et aussi c'est des méthodes
beaucoup plus modernes je crois qu'il
faut aller surtout sur ce sur ce critère
là je sais pas si l'intéressement
financier est une solution réellement
envisagée
av sans sans vouloir jouer les anciens
combattants mais la taxe professionnelle
c'était ça hein c'estàdire que vous avz
ici là on voit une une industrie
chimique il y en avait dans la métropole
lilloise il y en avait dans le bassin
minier il y en avait dans laassre il y
en avait dans le dans le derquis ça ça
rapporta aux communes et ça créa des
services et les habitants s'y
retrouvaient il y avait un espèce de de
donnant donnant hein dans cette affaire
il y avait un intérement financier à
partir de moment on la supprime et ben
on avait pu espèce d'intérêt à voir la
désindustrialisation elle arrive aussi
pour des raisons fiscales moi j'ai été
maire pendant 20 ans et donc il y avait
plus d'intérêt à accueillir de
l'industrie c'est ou puis ça nous
arrangeit aussi je reprends ce que
disait ce que disait j ci tout à l'heure
c'est ça nous arrangeit aussi de de
laisser la pollution se faire ailleurs
quoi vous voyez ce que je veux dire mais
l'intérêt financier c'est pour les
communes alors c'est le sénateur qui
parle c'est c'est une vraie question
parce que si vous avez un intérêt
financier vous créez des services pour
la population des crèches et et donc il
y a un avantage c'était ça l'industrie
autrefois ça doit redevenir ça il y a un
intérêt pour la population c'est pas
seulement en terme d'emploi c'est la
richesse globale et donc à ce moment-là
on mesure mieux les inconvénients les
avantages on doit être économe enfin on
voit bien les flux de de de richesse
tandis qu'à partir du moment où tout ça
s'est effacé et bien on avait plus
intérêt à avir les camions et les
nuisance c'est une vraie question moi je
suis favorable à recréer ce type d'impôt
c'est vrai pour les maires et sans doute
pour les les les les patrons des
collectivités non je crois que les
habitants justement ils se rendaient pas
compte du lien entre la taxe
professionnelle et et le fait
d'avoir services public et non parce que
tout ça ça arrivé à enfin voilà c'était
les moyens de la maie des collec bien
payé hein c'est toute une culture Heou
oui mais je veux dire la taxe
professionnelle je suis pas sûr mais je
pense que les ma s'en sont rendu compte
quand je pense que c'est un levier qui
est quand même très important pour
l'acceptabilité Émilie oui j'ai
l'impression que ça relève aussi d'un
espèce d'aménagement du territoire qui
changerait un petit peu de braqué parce
que comme vous l'avez dit par exemple
dans le nord des régions
désindustrialisées des villes moyennes
qui se sentent un peu abandon
et c'est une espèce de redynamisation
parce qu'on sait que ces usines elles
vont pas être en pleine métropole grande
métropole donc c'est plutôt dans ces
territoires là peut-être là où il y a
déjà de l'industrie donc c'est déjà plus
accepté quand il y a déjà eu une
industrie on accepte plus facilement
qu'il y en ait une autre qui s'installe
ou alors que ça se complète et puis ça
fait revivre en effet tout ce que vous
avez dit ça amène des infrastructures de
transport en tout cas si l'aménagement
du territoire était pensé comme ça ça
donnerait une deuxième vie en tout cas
un second sou assez ville et je pense
qu'elles ont saisi ça ouais prent
l'espèce de feuille de route tout ce qui
pourrait se déclencher grâce à
l'ouverture d'une mine propre c'est un
oxyor ou ou c'est possible euh alors non
c'est pas possible même si en tout cas
le projet qui est présenté est
impressionnant où ils essayent de faire
le maximum parce que je pense qu'ils ont
bien compris qu'ils étaient pas au
milieu du désert australien qui a une
des sources principales de lithium et
que les la France est un pays beaucoup
plus petit donc on rencontre des gens
très rapidement ils font tout leur
possible mais ça n'est pas possible il
faut voilà je je avoir l'impression de
répéter mais il faut qu'on réalise que
tous nos objets ce sublime studio est
fait grâce à des matières premières
extraites au 4 certainement pas mal
d'énergie fossile pour avoir prod
d'nergie fossile euh donc non ça
n'existera pas mais comme vous le dites
je pense qu'il faut avoir une vision et
que ça devienne un
projet j'ai tendance à penser que c'est
plus compliqué quelque part presque avec
des objets très technologiques comme le
lithium batterie voiture électrique que
peut-être des choses plus basiques on va
revenir sur un historique du du Nord ou
peut-être textile je pense que par
exemple sur des sujets comme ça
l'attachement de la population serait
plus facile même s'il y a des des pardon
des impact écologique là on est sur un
produit très technique où j'ai tendance
à penser que l'attachement va être plus
compliqué que sur des éléments plus
basiques même si c'est peut-être ce sera
peut-être la base de notre capacité à
garder notre mobilité et le modèle le
bon vieux modèle de la bagnole voyez ce
que je veux dire c'est donc peut-être
qu'on va les adorer nos batteries
électriques pour garder ce modèle bref
c'est un are débat jeis rest le bilan de
d'émanel Macron en matière de je vais
garder ce terme
réindustrialisation selon le
gouvernement depuis 2017 un sol de
positif de 20000 emplois industriels et
de
314 usine Elisabeth borne la première
ministre elle parle d'un marché du
travail
libéré depuis 2017 la
réindustrialisation est au cœur de
l'ambition portée par le Président de la
République nous avons restauré la
compétitivité des
entreprises libérer le marché du travail
investi dans les compétences et dans les
secteurs clés pour notre avenir avec
France
2030 encore récemment nous avons levé
les obstacles à l'implantation d'usine
avec le projet de loi industrie verte
cette politique porte ses fruits elle a
permis la création de 2 millions
d'emplois et la réouverture de 300
usines Émilie la réindustrialisation
voilà un thème un axe de communication
porteur pour le président de la
République oui c'est plutôt porteur
comme axe de communication il y a
plusieurs raisons à cela déjà des
résultats elle en parle les bborn ils
sont encore fragiles mais ils sont là
quelques donné des emplois industriels
qui repartent à la hausse après le
million disparu ces dernières décennies
euh des créations d'usines aussi qui
sont dynamiques une attractivité
française pour les investissements
étrangers qui est en bonne forme et puis
le sujet a un écho particulier auprès de
la population française et on en a parlé
surtout depuis la crise covid à ce
moment-là tout le monde s'est rendu
compte que c'était une aberration comme
on disait de pas pouvoir produire ne
serait-ce que des médicaments vous
parliez du paracétamol sur place de
dépendre aussi trop de la Chine
évidemment ça paraissait complètement
délirant est-ce qu'il y a une action
volontariste de la part de de l'exécutif
oui le sujet de la de la reconquête
industrielle c'était même dans le
programme du candidat Emmanuel Macron en
2017 et puis le président quinkena 1 et
quinkena 2 a multiplié les mesures
volontaristes alors surtout hein depuis
la crise sanitaire en 2020 le plan
France relance le plan France 2030 les
territoires d'industrie la baisse des
impôts de production les sites clés en
main et la loi toute récente industrie
verte Macron s'est d'ailleurs servi de
ce thème je sais pas si vous vous en
souvenez pour sortir un petit peu du
bourbier de la réforme des retraites au
printemps 2023 c'était assez bien réussi
c'était dans le cadre des ces 100 jours
d'action et d'apaisement et puis le
thème de la réindustrialisation on en
parlait juste à l'instant ça permet
aussi de parler à ces villes moyennes
qui se sentent un peu abandonné et à un
électorat qui est tenté par le
rassemblement national à cause de cet
abandon qui peuvent être des terres
d'accueil de ces industries alors quels
sont son les limites de cette
communication alors cette
réindustriisation elle est encore
fragile le baromètre de traino c'est un
cabinet qui scrute un peu les créations
et les fermetures d'usine qui dit que
c'est dynamique vous l'avez dit commence
à sentir une petite stagnation dans les
ouvertures d'usine il y a aussi des
problèmes structurels qui pèsent sur la
France en premier lieu la main d'œuvre
avec une industrie et on l'a dit à
l'instant qui peine à attirer les jeunes
ils ont une image encore très vieillote
de l'industrie qui pourtant se modernise
il y a aussi la question de la formation
c'est un peu les dégâts du en même temps
c'està-dire on veut la
réindustrialisation mais on arrête le
financement des formations longues qui
sont pourtant indispensables à ces
métiers et puis il y a un autre problème
c'est le foncier la France manque de
terrain pour les industriels et
notamment de grands terrains et les
nouveaux enjeux environnementaux et les
MRES en parlent beaucoup sortir un sigle
le zéro artificialisation nette des sols
le zan en effet ça facilite pas les
choses he c'est bien connu dans la tête
des mers résultat il y a des mastodontes
comme Tesla qui choisissent d'autres
pays européens l'Allemagne en
l'occurrence pour monter le leurs usines
il prévoient Tesla de de faire leur
première voiture électrique à 25000 € en
Allemagne et pas chez nous malgré tout
ce que Macron a essayé de faire le taux
de chômage aussi est reparti un petit
peu à la hausse et je suis pas sûr que
le grand réveillez-vous qu' a crié
Emmanuel Macron auprès des chefs
d'entreprise à l'Élysée en novembre il y
a pas très longtemps puis on peut
changer la donne il semble que ça soit
plutôt le reflet d'un président qui
commence à réaliser que l'un de ses
thèmes porteurs hein pourrait lui
échapper parce que la situation est
encore assez fragile alors ça ouvre
merci beaucoup Émilie beaucoup de de de
thèmes on reviendra longuement sur le
zéro artificialisation net on on
évoquera aussi les probl les questions
d'attractivité d'image de l'industrie et
donc de recrutement mais je démarre avec
vous Christine cardéan sur ces derniers
chiff de Trendo là l'observatoire de
l'emploi et de l'investissement l'année
2023 elle est quasi finie elle sera quoi
elle sera mauvaise elle sera beaucoup
moins bonne que les précédent qu'est-ce
sera moin bonne que les précédentes sera
encore bonne je crois qu'il va y avoir
20 un écart de 20 entre le nombre
d'usines fermé mais et le nombre
d'usines ouvertes donc on est on est
beaucoup moins que ce qu'on a eu sur les
6 dernières années oui euh je voudrais
préciser peut-être quand même pour
rendre à César ce qui appartient à César
que ce bon contexte ce contexte
sympathique pour les entreprises il a
certes été accentué par emmanuelron
Macron mais il avait commencé par le
virage le fameux virage de l'offre de
François Hollande en 2014 c'est lui qui
a commencé à faire un pacte de
responsabilité avec les entreprises pour
essayer en leur baissant les charges de
les convaincre d' compétitivité emploi
effectivement c'est depuis 2014 qu'on a
ce contexte porteur qui a permis toutes
ces ouvertures d'usine Olivier quel
bilan faites-vous de l'action desmanu
Macron en matière d'investissement
industrielah nous encore une fois on a
eu le le déclin industriel à gérer
pendant des années avec les friches
notamment donc aujourd'hui il y a il y a
un rebond industriel il y a un renouveau
industriel et donc on fait
pas c'est une réalité l'État a géré sa
part et d'ailleurs c'est tellement vrai
qu'on arrive à la question
du
zan 3000 la question plus tard arrê
arrêrê disponibleoiou je vous poserai la
question sur les friches mais le bilan
d'Emmanuel Macron quelle part de du du
volontarisme c'est intéressant parce que
il y a aussi ce que la région a fait
vous nous avez cité Xavier Bertrand ça
n'était ça n'est possible ce qui se
passe dans dans dans la région depuis
des années que si et l'État et la région
et et les élus tirent dans le même sens
c'est ce qui s'est passé ah bah
naturellement quand on accueille un un
projet de cette ampleur il y a le rôle
de l'impulsion de l'État il y a le le
rôle du du gouvernement il y a le préfet
qui il y a la région et il y a le
collectivité
territorialeme à l'Europe elle participe
au au au au
financement c'est pas c'est pas rien
mais c'est l'Europe c'est toujours un
acteur qui se fait discret au fond suj
c'est
dommage la réalité voyez moi je suis je
suis comment dire j'ai milité en faveur
de l'Europe et cetera je milite toujours
mais vous voyez même moi j'y pense pas
spontanément pourtant je crois à l'idéal
européen mais c'est très français mais
c'est un c'està-dire il se fait discret
on le voit Pasin mais dans le dans dans
le financement de ce genre de de grand
projets il est présent naturellement ou
Jérôme cunil on parle on parle d'un
tassement là euh est-ce que c'est sur
cette réindustrialisation est-ce que
c'est un tassement temporaire est-ce
qu'il y a quand même un mouvement de
fond qui pourrait continuer ou alors je
vais poser la question différent quelles
sont les explications voyez ce que je
veux dire parce que l'industrie c'est
une composante de l'économie générale et
que le champion industriel européen
l'Allemagne est en récession la France
en sort presque bien combien de temps
croisons les doigts et l'industrie suit
la même dynamique et c'est dommage parce
qu'il y avait une dynamique avec un sol
positif qui on voit baisser chaque année
malheureusement parce qu'il y a quand
même des disparitions faut jamais
oublier he c'est un solde net dont on
parle oui c'est plus 314 mais il y a eu
évidemment des fer d'usine VO et donc ça
suit la même Dyam
H c je dejss cblage pour ne pas perdre
complèette dynamique êre beaucoup plus
ciblé et le rôle des collectivités
territoriales je pense qu'on leur laisse
pas encore assez la main en fait elles
l'ont pas mal mais on s'aperçoit dans
les études qu'elles jouent un rôle
énorme pour l'implantation
l'attractivité elles connaissent leur
territoire et on leur laisse pas assez
de rôle et l'état parfois garde
peut-être un peu trop la main sur
certains projets il me semble sur
l'Europe qui a quand même cette question
je le disais à l'instant il y a une
concurrence finalement entre les pays
européens donc ce qui est quand même
assez dramatique parce que on pourrait
se dire comme on a eu Airbus qu'on
pourrait mettre not nos forces ensemble
selon les secteurs et décider qui est un
meneur pour tel secteur ou quoi et on
narrive pas parce qu'onindustrie verte
européenne on n pas de stratégie
réellement européenne et du coup on se
fait concurrence qui est quand même
assez catastrophique dans la logique des
choses on pourrait voir émerger il y a
des projets he d'intérêts nationaux qui
commencent à émerger donc on on focalise
toutes nos forces comme les piles à
combustible ou quoi mais ça reste encore
assez discret et en effet je trouve que
l'Europe est assez discrète y compris en
terme de protectionnisme à l'image de ce
que font les États-Unis pour protéger un
peu notre économie il y a ça aussi il y
a une tentative d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
même puisque deux dirigeants européens
Ursula V derlen et Charles Michel sont à
Pékin Christine ceréan il négocient avec
quel résultat on verra bien mais en tout
cas ils essayent d'obtenir un
rééquilibrage des échanges avec la Chine
comment vous l'analysez ça est-ce que
l'Europe commence à sortir de sa naïvé
ou peut-être même sortir d'un d'un dogme
de libre échange mondial qui expliquait
sa capacité à laisser les portes grandes
ouvertte l'Europe a été naïve c'est
clair puisque maintenant on se rend
compte qu'elle est beaucoup moins mais
le mot politique industrielle par
exemple la France l'employait on était
stigmatisé pour l'employé mais mais en
même temps l'Allemagne a toujours fait
une politique industrielle les
États-Unis l'IRA c'est une énorme
politique
industrielle reduction Act qui en fait
est un aspirateur à à pro la fois des
subventions pour les pour les projets
c'est utiliser le prix de l'énergie qui
est beaucoup moins cher et puis et puis
protéger les les frontières américaines
en disant si vous fabriquez une voiture
ici vous aurez 7500 € de des enfin les
gens auront une 7500 € de moins à payer
sur le prix de la voiture ça l'urope
c'est fait donc ça ça justement l'Europe
c'est pas faire voilà donc la Chine elle
l'a fait sans le dire mais de manière
énorme le protectionnisme chinois
regardez les même les Google les
Amazones et CETA on pas réussi à
s'introduire en Chine c'est dire à quel
point les les frontières étaient
nettesou les États-Unis l'ont fait et
ben l'Europe elle elle l'a jamais fait
alors on commence timidement on commence
à à faire un certain nombre de projets
alors tout à l'heure je trouvais que
vous étiez injuste parce que les pques
par exemple tout le monde en a un peu
entendu parler des projets d'intérêt
important euh d'intérêt national oui
d'intérêt national c'est européen oui
c'est européen et ça permet notamment de
financer des des des usines des giga des
giga factories pour les pour les les les
les batteries des voitures donc ça
l'Europe a est monté au créneau sur ça
sur les semionducteurs alors
effectivement c'est l'Allemagne qui a
ramassé le gros lot en ayant les deux
usines de semionducteur importantes en
Europe mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que globalement ça va profiter quand
même à tout le continent sur cette
naïveté ou cette capacité de l'Europe à
mieux se défendre ça veut dire quoi si
on prend tiens l'exemple des voitures
électriques chinoises qui arrivent à
très bas prix sur le marché européen il
semblerait qu'ell soit en grande partie
ou en partie subventionné par l'État
chinois donc qu'est- c'est quoi la
réponse possible de l'Europe c'est des
droit de douane c'est théoriquement on a
le mécanisme d'ajustement du carbone aux
frontières MCF je crois qui arrive en
2027 qui est loin d'être parfait mais
qui est
théoriquement des sortes de barrières
douanières mais avec un aspect
environnemental mais 2027 il y aur on
sera tout roulera tous en voiture
chinoise hein d'ici alors
j' mais on en est très très loin même si
la courbe de la proportion d'achat de
véhicule neuf électrique explose on est
très loin mais c'est sûr aussi qu'il y a
eu le positionnement des constructeurs
français qui on leur a toujours reproché
d'être dans le milieu de gamme qui ont
essayé de faire du parce que c'est là
qu'il font de la marge vendent des
toutes petites voitures on gagne moins
d'argent et électrique ou thermique he
c'est à peu près le même sujet la Bonne
Nouvelle ils sortent des modèles l'état
imposé des systèmes entre autres essayer
d'avoir une voiture électrique
disponible avec pour 100 € par mois tout
ça devrait aider on l'espère mais il y a
pas de conditions sur ce système par
exemple de mensualisation il y a pas de
conditions sur la provenance de la
voiture donc ça pose des questions mais
c'est vrai qu'on a été plus royaliste
que le roi c'estàd qu'on a ouvert toutes
les barrières alors que les grands
autres pôles du monde sont fait tout ce
qu'ils souhaitaent ou j'ai l'espoir que
ce mécanisme de contrôle carbone aux
frontières va aider mais il est sûrement
trop léger sûrement c'est sûr donc ça
rendrait plus cher tous les
projets ch qui produit encore beaucoup
son électricité avec du charbon ou
Olivier h que peut faire l'Europe là
pour on est dans ce dans ce contexte de
réindustrialisation on est en train de
dire que ça s'essouffle un petit peu
c'est quoi c'est effectivement sortir de
la naïveté des droits de douan
protectionnisme c'est quoi la pas que
l'EUR a été naïve elle a été dogmatique
je pense que pour connaître un peu la la
direction de la concurrence européenne
qui est une la compétence hein a été axé
sur une question c'est le moindre prix
pour le
consommateur et et donc ce ce ce dogme
ça a marché d'un certain point de vue on
est je veux dire le consommateur a
souvent par la concurrence eu des
produits qui étaient d'une qualité
correcte et pas et pas très cher qui
venait de souvent de très très loin
c'était aussi la modialisation qui per
la naïeté c'était un choix quand vous
allez à Bruxelles à la direction pour
pour avoir commis un rapport sur ce
sujet la la direction de la concurrence
européenne elle est tournée sur cette
question le moindre prix pour le
consomateur quand même oui est s cette
influence donc il faut faire ce
retournement et afficher un autre choix
stratégique la question elle est là
c'est aussi une des question il faut pas
s'étonner c'est le choix stratégique une
politique industrielle préserver nos
intérêts il faut faire ce retournement
stratégique et afficher cet objectif et
et c'est un retournement par rapport à à
à la direction de la concurrence qui est
encore y compris les dirigeants
européens sur ce cette concurrence
interne à l'Europe plutôt que se
protéger par rapport à un environnement
international qui a changé et la fin du
multilatéralisme qui est quand même un
peu devant nous elle a quand même un peu
évolué l'Europe parce que les les
champions européens qu'on ne pouvait pas
créer les mariages entre Alstom S et
cetera on pouvait pas créer on pouvait
pas créer de champion européen parce que
cette direction de la concurrence parce
que l'Europe voulait empêcher dans
l'intérêt du consommateur que qu'on
fusionne des gens
qui créer des géants pour concurrencer
les Américains ou les
Chinois géant on nit pas de géant pour
concurrencer les autres effectivement et
ça ça a évolué ils ont je crois que
c'est ti Bruton et un certain nombre
d'autres ont quand même agi pour alors
un chiffre que c'est la part de
l'industrie dans le produit intérieur
brut français en 1970 on était à 20 %
donc si je car enfin si je schématise un
peu 20 % de la richesse française venait
de l'industrie 2022 9,5 % et l'objectif
affiché par le gouvernement c'est 15 %
sauf que Bruno Le Maire quand il annonce
ce chiffre bah il précise pas à quelle
échéance Jérôme cudit bon il y a il y a
l'ambition affichée mais il y a la
question de la
vision est-ce qu' est-ce que d'après
vous il y a une vision associée à cette
ambition et si oui laquelle ben on le
voit par les multiples contraintes qui
viennent parce qu'on prend l'angle de
l'industrie mais on est sur une
problématique systémique de l'économie
en général de notre consommation et en
fait c'est ce qui je trouve manque un
petit peu dans la composante
industrielle mais dans France 2030 en
général c'est qu'on a un peu une liste
d'axes de développement technologique et
technique qui sont très
enthousiasm30 c'est quoi un grand plan
d'investis voilà c'est la vision en 10
points de développement de la France
mais qui a trop un aspect technique et
je pense qu'il manque toute cette vision
politique c'estd mais ça serit quoi ça
veut dire quoi une vision politique sur
la matière c'est quel secteur quel
secteur en privilégie ça ve dire
produire quoi produire quoi c'est aussi
simple que ça on la question pour moi
n'a été posée nulle part c'est-à-dire
produit technique la voiture électrique
c'est attractif c'est visible on va
pouvoir peut-être en exporter j'ai envie
de dire et entre autre ça rejoint à
nouveau la question du Nord moi
j'entends parler nulle part de textile
c'est on l'importe à 95 % en France
peut-être ça serait quelque chose de
plus basique peut-être moins sexy hein
si je peux me le permettre mais qui est
absolument indispensable moins technique
moins polluant mais pardon on revient à
la question de du prix enfin vous nous
avez dit bah finalement le dogme
européen c'était les produits les moins
chers possibles pour les consommateurs
on a donc aussi notre part de
responsabilité dans la
desindustrialisation hein disons-le donc
ok on on réindustrialise le textile bah
ça veut dire que les vêtements vont
forcément coûter plus cher bien sûr mais
c'est changer notre relation aux objets
oui non mais
jeis maintenant qu'on réalise que
fabriquer produire consommer un impact
sur l'environnement à toutes les
échelles du changement climatique à
l'usage de l'eau il faut peut-être qu'on
réalise que vendre au volume n'est plus
le modèle mais en pleine période
d'inflation c'est un discours qui est
voilà qui est peut-être un peu plusile
politiquement à à porter moi je trouve
que l'Europe quand même se réveille tant
mieux un peu tardivement il me semble
mais il faudrait pas louper non plus les
coches il il y a cette histoire de
savoir vraiment où ce qu'on va produire
en France décider ou quoi est-ce qu'on
produit en Europe mais il y a aussi la
question de l'énergie et moi j'ai
l'impression qu'on prend du retard parce
qu'on voit bien que les États-Unis
s'organisent on voit bien qu'il y en a
on sait qu'il vaut mieux que les usines
produisent et consomment leur énergie
sur place il y a des il y a même les les
fameux small SMR là les petits réacteurs
nucléaires qui commencent à à poindre en
Chine aux États-Unis parce que c'est une
solution justement pour et ça permet de
baisser le coût de l'énergie il y a
cette question là et la question du
social parce que je pense qu'aux
États-Unis ils sont très vigilants à
faire attention parce qu'on l' dit il y
a pas peu d'attractivité pour ces
métiers pour changer la donne nous on on
a des métiers des emplois qui sont pas
pourvus en industrie on risque de de
d'être un peu à cours de production à
cause de ça les États-Unis et certains
autres pays ont compris le truc avant
nous ils sont dit il va falloir mettre
des conditions des salaires des choses
beaucoup plus importantes il faudrait
pas qu'on loupe un deuxième coche
maintenant qu'on est prêt sur ces
aspectsl et moi il me semble qu'on est
parti c'est ça qui est étonnant c'est
qu'on est parti un peu h tard sur
l'industrie mais par contre on est parti
très tôt ce qui est bien dans l'absolu
sur la décarbonation et sur T ces
enjeuxlà mais ça nous ça nous met aussi
en difficulté parce que ça coûte plus
cher de produirepr donc voilà il faut
c'est vrai qu'on manque un peu de
stratégie en se disant qu'est-ce qu'on
fait en premier qu'est-ce qu'on fait
ensite et comment on fait en parallèle
le constat jeis quand même que pour une
fois qu'on a des nouvelles correctes con
est quand même positif on est quandme de
réindustrialiserovme positif France 2030
je trouve qu'il a quand même une vision
assez claire parce que c'est lié
justement à l'énergie comme vous le
disiez c'est laère hydrogène c'est la
voiture électrique propre c'est
justement les Small SMR c'est les petits
réacteurs nucléaires qui vont qu'on peut
mettre un peu partout peut CR on réaur
nu pouroi faire l'avion à hydrogène je
suis désolé tout le monde sait que ça
n'a pas d'avenir tout le monde dans le
secteur sait qu'on
aura 35 mil aura pas 35 millions de
voitures électriques il faut être
honnête avec les Français il y a 35
millions de voitures thermiques il n en
aura pas c'est incrit dans le
secrétariat planification écologique
eux-même la France aura besoin de 5 % du
lithium mondial après 2030 nous sommes
0,8 % de la population mondiale il va
falloir faire des choix ça en fait des
mines à ouvrir bon alors il y a il y a
un mot puisqueon ce qui est intéressant
dans ce débat c'est que il y a il y a il
y a toutes les contradiction potentielle
de effectivement la la transformation la
transition écologique la transformation
environnementale et on va choisir ce cle
dont vous nous parliez tout à l'heure
pour RER les fameux Z et c'est Tran qui
va tout de suite venir nous en parler
elle doit être juste derrière le rideau
magique de sens public rebonsoir tamame
zéro artificialisation déjà faut réussir
à le prononcer net oui hein pour
commencer le zan kzako hein on l'entend
beaucoup sur ce plateau cet acronyme
barbare mais aussi dans la bouche d'élus
locaux inquiè c'est un objectif qui a
été fixé par la loi climat et résilience
de 2021 il prévoit deux choses pour
stopper l'artificialisation des sols
rappelons que c'est un enjeu essentiel
pour limiter le réchauffement climatique
et pour préserver la biodiversité
d'abord réduire de moitié d'ici 2030
l'artificialisation des sols la
construction sur des espaces naturels et
agricoles par rapport à la décennie
précédente et puis le deuxième objectif
c'est horizon 2050 tout simplement
interdire de bétonner à moins de
renaturer une surface équivalente tout
ce qui sera pris devra être rendu la
question qui se pose alors c'est est-ce
que le zan va empêcher la construction
des usines nécessaires dans le cadre
notre de notre réindustrialisation le
débat il est politique il fait rage
entre la vision par exemple de Laurent
vquier qui veut sortir sa région duusan
et ses élus de gauche d'van ronalp qui
disent aujourd'hui dans le monde que
c'est tout à fait possible en misant sur
l'innovation ils ont publié une tribune
aujourd'hui alors voilà est-ce que le
zan c'est une usine à gaz est-ce que
c'est un obstacle total ou est-ce que
c'est un défi à relever et à ces
questions le Parlement a commencé à y
répondre avec une nouvelle et oui moins
de 2 ans après la loi climat et
résilience l'été dernier les
parlementaires ont adopté quasiment à
l'unanimité un texte pour assouplir le
zéro artificialisation net au cœur de
cette loi ce sujet des grands projets
d'envergure national he comme les
infrastructure de transport ou encore
les grands projets industriels les mares
n'avaient qu'une crainte qu'accueillir
un tel projet tous ces hectares amputent
leur sold du coup les parlementaires ont
trouvé une solution astucieuse ces
hectares vont être comptés à part et
seront déduits de l'enveloppe globale
nationale de zân et réparti entre les
régions car oui Thomas les
parlementaires ne sont pas des zânes
batté bonne blague cela n'a pas fait
taire toutes les inquiétudes loin de là
et oui est-ce que ça sera suffisant
quand on a ce genre d'inquiétude en
France bah vous savez on fait une loi on
en a même fait deux puis on peut aussi
commander un rapport le rapport sur le
zan il a été rémis juste après cette loi
par le préfet Roland Mouchel blzo au
mois d'août dernier un rapport pour
éviter le divorce entre l'écologie et
l'industrie un rapport qui propose
l'optimisation des zones industrielles
d'abord il faut bah gagner de la place
optimiser les espaces extérieurs
mutualiser les services au salariés
densifier les sites industriels en
vertical une idée qui a déjà fleuri dans
l'idée de dans l'esprit de certains
comme cette entrepreneur dans la région
de Rennes que notre journaliste Flora
sauvage avait interrogé écout pendant
très longtemps on se posait pas trop la
question et donc on travaillait au sol
et on noptimisait pas forcément les
mètres cubes de nos usines je pense que
l'avenir il va passer dans le
l'optimisation des mètres cubes au lieu
de l'optimisation des mètres carrés
quand on voit les nos fournisseurs
italiens ils ont déjà depuis très
longtemps dans le nord de l'Italie des
usines à étag et donc forcément on va
tous aller vers là le rapport donne
aussi une estimation du foncier
nécessaire d'ici 2030 pour l'industrie
il faut 22000 hactares dont 19500 pour
l'industrie à proprement parler 2500
pour la logistique associée et pour cela
et bien mise aussi sur la reconversion
des friches industrielles rapport estime
qu'il faut réhabiliter 10000 hectares de
friche d'ici 2030 coût minimum 1
milliard d'euros il faut donc trouver
des solutions de financement merci
beaucoup Tam les les parlementaires ne
sont pas des Anne baté donc vous vouliez
être au bêtisier 2023 c'est ça ben vous
y êtes merci beaucoup merci d'être venu
sur ce plateau je redeviens sérieux et
je me tourne vers vous évidemment
Olivier vous avez commencé à répondre à
la question tout à l'heure sur ces
friches industriel là il y en a encore
presque plus dans dans votre région il y
en a de moins en moins mais voyez je
reviens sur leusanne bon la vérité c'est
que on pouvait plus dans le monde qui
s'ouvre continuer comme avant on pouvait
pas faire consommer un hectare pour pour
faire quelques maisons avec 2000 m² de
terrain voyez il y avait quand même il
fallait mettre on était en train de
faire un peu partout du Los Angeles du
petit Los Angeles et donc ça c'était pas
du tout adapté au monde qui venait donc
il fallait réfléchir sur la consommation
de l'espace on a peut-être été un pe
trop brutal si j'ose dire d'où d'où
l'assouplissement et donc consommer de
l'espace pour des industries nouvelles
pour faire la la reconversion écologique
de de l'industrie ça je pense qu'il faut
réouvrir la porte par rapport à tout ça
consommer de l'espace pour des logements
nouveaux comme un inerc quand on va
accueillir 30000 emplois avec les giga
factorie et et la vallé des batteries va
bien falloir le faire mais par contre
faire des lotissement tout communes ça
c'est fin et ilait il fallait quand même
tourner la page de ça alors peut-être
qu'on a fait mal brutalement mais et que
aujourd'hui il faut réfléchir mais on
peut pas revenir avant le Pass fauter le
principe garderp heureusement qu'on
l'assoup quoi si je comprends bien ah
oui ça il fallait l'assouplir on l'
assoup mais peut-être encore faut-il
c'est la question des choix voyez les
enjeux géostratégiques on en parlait
est-ce que par exemple il faut discuter
avec la Chine moi je suis président de
du groupe d'amitié avec l'Asie du
Sud-Est ils sont eux ils veulent
discuter Thaïlande Philippines et cetera
plutôt pour ouvrir les taux ils sont
pris en étau entre la Chine et l'Inde
donc on doit cibler des objectifs en
terme de de de de d'échange et là on
doit cibler aussi les nos objectifs et
nos objectifs si c'est la
réindustrialisation si c'est un nouvel
hisire industriel à ce moment-là il faut
donner un peu plus de possibilités aux
élus locaux régions pour aménager
l'espace on a été beaucoup trop rigide
c'est un État jacobin qui a voulu
imprimer une logique et ça c'est un peu
le défaut français Jérôme cuni est-ce
qu'on est en train d'assister à une
fronde en tisane au sein des des
conseils municipaux un petit peu je
pense que c'est important de rappeler
pourquoi quand même hein parce qu'on
finit par l'oublier derrière que à
chaque fois qu'on met du béton ou du
bitume sur la terre elle ne capture plus
de carbone l'eau ne part plus dans le
sol et au passage ça agve les
inondations exactement et à chaque fois
la
biodiversité est affecté par la
réduction de ses espaces de vie donc il
faut pas oublier qu'on l'a pas fait
juste pour embêter les mes bien sûr
évidment mais la la question et là on
est au cur de notre débat est-ce que
c'est compatible c'est est-ce qu'on peut
réindustrialiser un pays et en même
temps dire aux élus zéro
artificialisation net ben tout arrive en
même temps parce qu'on a trop attendu
hein soyons clair c'est ça qui est dur
en fait c'est on a tellement attendu
qu'on a l'impression que tout arrive
alors je comprends qu'on assouplisse et
je pense que la stratégie est pas
mauvaise c'est-à-dire on y va un peu dur
on assouplit mais soyons clair les
objectifs vont pas tellement changer et
ça va être compliqué pour les les
collectivités on revient l'idée qu'il va
falloir faire des choix et vivre avec la
nature en fait on a considéré que
c'était euh comment infini et qu'on
allait faire ce qu'on souhaitait on
réalise la nature avec le changement
climatique les sécheresses et hautes
nous dit mais en fait ça fonctionne pas
comme ça vous ne pouvez pas mettre du
béton partout et que ça fonctionne comme
avant c'est aussi simple que ça on a
cassé un système naturel le problème
c'est que ça nous oblige à revoir notre
système sur la manière dont on vit nous
oui et et notre modèle parce que quand
quand je vous entends parler des des
lotissements Chine card c'est un peu
enfin ça me rappelle une ministre qui
avait dit que il fallait abandonner les
la maison individuelle et cetera et
cetera bon elle s'était fait Emmanuel
vargon de mémoire elle s'était fait
assez pulvérisé par la médiasphère on va
dire ça comme ça mais c'est ce que vous
êtes en train de nous dire c'est ce
modèle qui est pas seulement français
mais très français du rêve de la maison
individuelle est-ce que c'est là aussi
compati bah si c'est
uni on peut avoir des maisons
individuelles avec des jardins c'est on
a quand même abusé on a on a réfléchi on
a agi plutôt comme si l'espace était
infini mais on n'est pas obligé non plus
de de de d'être à l'horizontale à
l'excès hein à la verticale à l'excès
pardonnez-moi je je je pense que c'est
pas fini la
maison ou même des appartements bien
aménagés hein il y a aussi la qualité
architecturale il faut pas non plus
comment dire être pessimiste ou avoir
une
[Musique]
vision
ma il y a des espaces qui sont aménagés
où chacun son petit jardin son espace
vert on peut vivre avec la nature et et
et et et et être en harmonie avec la
nature quand même faut pas
désespérer oui non mais je pense que le
problème des surfaces est un problème
parmi d'autres quand vous voyez le le le
l'entreprise al c'est pas celle qu'on
voit tout à l'heure mais breton le duf
ils avaient la surface ils avaient les
employés et puis finalement il y a pas
eu d'acceptation des des des habitants
autour parce que cette usine de
viennoiserie allait utiliser trop d'eau
et donc ça allait prendre tellement de
temps il y avit av des recours et cetera
que il a fini par dire ça va prendre 8
ans moi je peux pas les concurrents ils
sont en train d'ouvrir deses maintenant
c'est maintenant que j'ai besoin de le
faire donc effectivement il y a un
problème de surface à chaque fois qu'on
en parle Emmanuel Macron répond mais il
y a les friches industrielles mais il y
a les friches industrielles commençons
par les
occuper ce que disait le le le
l'industriel penser en mère CUB plutôt
qu'en mèt Carr ça effectivement c'est
très intéressant c'est effectivement une
une bonne une bonne solution est-ce que
vous êtes globalement optimiste quand
même parce que comment vous sortez d'un
débat comme ça surcuni
euh oui je suis optimiste parce que moi
il y a une dynamique le travail qui a
été fait par le secrétariat la
planification écologique qui inclut
comment se déplacer et quoi enfin
comment produire nous donne enfin une
une une route elle est très complexe si
vous avez déjà vu le graphique elle est
c'est un un gâteau à 1000 étages on va
dire avec beaucoup de sous-composantes
mais au moins il y a un plan c'est déjà
une base il il me paraît très complexe à
mettre en place donc so optimiste parce
que nous allons en avoir besoin merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat je vais rappeler le titre de
votre livre Jérôme C relocaliser C
édition Tana dans la collection fake hor
note voilà je vous dis à lundi pour un
nouveau numéro de sens public et puis
noter que demain Orian mansini reçoit
Patrick stéphanini l'ancien secrétaire
général du ministère de l'immigration
qui vient de coécrire vous le savez un
rapport sur l'aide médicale d'État belle
soirée à toutes et à
tous
[Musique]